AUTOCRACY, WOLF?
>> WE'LL SEE HOW THIS UNFOLDS.
THANKS VERY MUCH FRED PLEITGEN
ON THE SCENE FROM UKRAINE.
LET'S BRING IN RETIRED U.S.
ATTORNEY GENERAL WESLEY CLARK
AND CONTRIBUTOR ON RUSSIAN
OFFICIALS JILL DOHERTY.
THESE MAJOR DEVELOPMENTS TODAY
WHEN IT COMES TO TANKS.
HOW BIG OF A GAME CHANGER
POTENTIALLY COULD BE THE GERMAN
LEOPARD TANK AND EVENTUALLY, THE
U.S. ABRAMS TANKS?
HOW BIG OF A CHANGE COULD THAT
BE ON THE BATTLE FIELD?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S VERY
SIGNIFICANT POLITICALLY, WOULD
WHICH.
IT DEPENDS HOW MANY TANKS.
ZELENSKYY SAYS HE NEEDS 500 TO
300 NEW TANKS.
HE MAY GET 100.
IT'S GOOD WITH A BREAKTHROUGH OR
SETS UP AN ARMORED BRIGADE TO
PUNCH IN THE SOUTH BUT UKRAINE
NEEDS THE LONG RANGE DRONES.
REALLY WOULD HELP TO HAVE
AIRCRAFT AND HAVE TO HOLD ON THE
EASTERN FRONT.
>> GOOD POINT.
JILL, WHAT MESSAGE DOES THIS
SEND WHEN IT COMES TO TANKS,
WHAT MESSAGE DOES THIS SEND TO
PUTIN?
THEY WERE ISSUING WARNINGS IF
YOU START SENDING TANKS TO
UKRAINE, THIS COULD BE A GAME
CHANGER FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE.
THEY WOULD SEE THE U.S. OR
GERMANY BEING PART OF THE
UKRAINIAN OFFENSIVE.
>> YOU KNOW, WOLF, THEY'RE
ALREADY SAYING NOT -- THEY'VE
BEEN SAYING IT SINCE THIS ISSUE
CAME UP THAT THIS WOULD BE
PLAYING BY FIRE.
THAT THE WEST WOULD BE RISKING
EXPANDING THE WAR, RISKING A
CONFRONTATION BETWEEN NATO AND
RUSSIA.
I MEAN, THE RUSSIANS ARE
THROWING AS MANY RED FLAGS UP AS
THEY CAN AND I THINK BECAUSE
THEY ARE WORRIED BECAUSE THESE
MAYBE NOT COMPLETE GAME CHANGERS
BUT THE RUSSIAN TANKS ARE NOT
ADEQUATE TO GO UP AGAINST NATO
TANKS, AND SO THEY'RE WORRIED,
THEY'RE SAYING THESE WOULD BE
LEGITIMATE TARGETS AND AGAIN,
THAT IT WOULD HURT RELATIONS
SPECIFICALLY WITH GERMANY BUT I
THINK THEY'RE WORRIED.
>> WE SHALL SEE.
THIS IS WHEN THEY ARE CUTTING
FORCES AND PLANNING AN OFFENSIVE
IN THE SOUTH.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
STRATEGY?
>> I THINK IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
IF IT'S POSSIBLE TO DO THAT BUT
ON THE OTHER HAND, YOU GOT TO BE
A LITTLE CAREFUL GIVING UP
GROUND IN THE EAST.
THAT'S REALLY TACTICAL
DECISIONS.
IT'S GREEK LINE OR RIVER LINE BY
RIVER LINE AND LOOKING AT LINES
OF COMMUNICATION AND ROAD
NETWORKS.
YES, WE NEED AN OFFENSIVE IN THE
SOUTH.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
CRITICAL TERRAIN IS CUTTING OFF
THE LAND BRIDGE INTO CRIMEA AND
THAT WOULD BE THE INTEINTENT.
THE IDEA WOULD BE TO MANEUVER
WAR
WARFARE, WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO
MATCH ARTILLERY SHELL FOR
ARTILLERY SHELL.
TO DO THAT, YOU CANNOT GIVE UP
THE EASTERN AREA.
YOU GOT TO FIND A WAY TO HOLD
IT.
CAN YOU GET MORE ADVANTAGE OF A
SITUATION?
MAYBE.
THIS IS A TOUGH CALL FOR
UKRAINIANS.
WHAT THEY WANT IS TO HOLD LEFT
AND PUNCH SOUTH.
TO DO THAT, THEY NEED MORE
TANKS, THEY NEED LONG RANGE
FIRES AND NEED THE LOGISTICS TO
KEEP IT ON THE BATTLE FIELD.
>> LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE ABOUT TO
START GETTING THAT.
WESLEY CLARK, JILL DOHERTY,
GUYS, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> LET'S CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION NOW WITH DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR RICHARD BLUMENTHAL OF
CONNECTICUT A KEY MEMBER OF THE
ARMED SERVICES COMMITTEE.
I KNOW YOU'RE JUST BACK SENATOR
FROM THIS BIPARTISAN DELEGATION
YOU WERE ON.
YOU WENT TO KYIV AND MET THERE
WITH PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY.
HOW SIGNIFICANT IS THIS APPARENT
BREAKTHROUGH FOR THE U.S. AND
ALLIES TO START PROVIDING ABRAMS
AND LEOPARD BATTLE TANKS TO
UKRAINE?
>> PROFOUNDLY SIGNIFICANT, WOLF.
WE HEARD AGAIN AND AGAIN, NOT
ONLY FROM PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
BUT FROM HIS TOP MILITARY
LEADERS THAT THESE TANKS,
REMEMBER THE FIREPOWER, THE
ARMOR THEY HAVE, THE MOBILITY
ARE ESSENTIAL TO DEFENDING
AGAINST THE ON SLOT, THE RUSSIAN
OFFENSE THAT IS ANTICIPATED NOT
MONTHS FROM NOW BUT LITERALLY
WEEKS AWAY.
ONE OF THE KEY MILITARY LEADERS
SAID TO ME WHY DON'T YOU TRUST
US?
IN EFFECT SAYING WE HAVE USED
WHAT YOU'VE GIVEN US TO SUCH
GREAT EFFECT, THEY PUSHED THEM
AWAY FROM KYIV, THE RUSSIANS.
THEY MADE MAJOR PROGRESS IN THE
EAST NOW THE CONFLICT IS
DEADLOCKED AND THE UKRAINIANS
WANT TO MOUNT THEIR OWN COUNTER
OFFENSE.
HERE IS THE KEY POINT, WOLF.
TIME.
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE.
TIME IS NOT ON THEIR SIDE.
SO THEY NEED THESE TANKS
LITERALLY TOMORROW.
NOT MONTHS FROM NOW.
TRAINING, TRANSPORT NEED TO BE
COMPRESSED.
>> BECAUSE YOU KEEP POINTING
OUT, SENATOR, THIS IS IN YOUR
WORDS A CRITICAL TURNING POINT
IN THE WAR THAT WE'RE SEEING
RIGHT NOW.
WHAT WILL IT TAKE IN THE
UPCOMING SPRING FIGHTING TO
CONVINCE PUTIN HE SIMPLY CAN'T
WIN IN UKRAINE?
>> WHAT IT WILL TAKE IS SUCCESS
ON THE GROUND.
AND OFFENSIVE THAT PUTS IN PLAY
CRIMEA AND POINTS CLOSE TO THE
BORDER WITH RUSSIA SO THAT PUTIN
FEELS THE HEAT OF THEIR
MILITARY.
THE TANKS ARE IMPORTANT AS A
MESSAGE TO PUTIN THAT HE'S NOT
GOING TO FRACTURE OR DIVIDE THE
ALLIES AS HAS BEEN PART OF HIS
GOAL ALL ALONG AND YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THE WAR IS AT A CRITICAL TURNING
POINT, A TIME OF MAXIMUM DANGER
BUT ALSO, MAJOR OPPORTUNITY.
AND I CAN'T EMPHASIZE STRONGLY
ENOUGH HOW IMPORTANT TIME IS AND
THERE IS A LARGER LESSON HERE,
WOLF, THAT I WOULD SAY WE ALL
OUGHT TO TAKE FROM THIS
EXPERIENCE.
WE HAVE PROVIDED WHAT IS NEEDED
WHEN THE UKRAINIANS HAVE
REQUESTED BUT OFTEN, ONLY AFTER
DELAY THE HIGH MARK ARTILLERY,
THE PATRIOT MISSILE DEFENSE,
SOME OF THE OTHER ARMS, WE NEED
TO TAKE THE LESSON TO SAY YES,
THAT OUGHT TO BE THE DEFAULT.
YES, UNTIL WE FI